our fifth script is street rat alley
punches her ticket written by Walker
McKnight when the leader of a gang of
homeless girls makes a deal with an
underworld boss to earn a ticket out of
her dome sealed city she and her street
urchin family become targets of every
criminal in the place human and
otherwise in this scene Ally the leader
of the Street rats and Moon Pie the next
oldest member thank you returned from
the streets to their sewer room hideout
with a hard-fought and stolen meal there
they join the rest of the gang and enjoy
a meal and a moment's respite from the
cruel city above interior the rat's nest
day Ally and Moon Pines Ally and Moon
Pies scramble down the ladder into the
rat's nest an old sewer access room 15
by 15 wood crate in the center their
table candles provide light a maze of
pipes covers the ceiling for tiny wood
plank beds hang from the walls each full
of old blankets a stream of sludge water
flows lazily through the center out of
one big drainage pipe and into another
alley reaches the floor looks push pop /
confused where's Rob what happened to
your hair
push pop has a kind of greased up
fauxhawk she Pat's it it's like a shark
fan go up it did it guppy 11 crawls in
from one pipe bright-eyed and eager
she's air dynamic now did you bring
anything to eat all four girls huddle
around their box table push pop and
guppy look hopeful Ally fakes a sad face
sorry cup just didn't make it happen
today
guppy tries to hide her heartbreak it's
okay we ate Tuesday Ally slams the dog
on the table guppy shrieks what is it
the best meal you ever ate find me a hot
pipe the girls blur into motion climbing
the walls using the backs of their hands
to test pipes number 6 is boiling Ally
carries the gaga produces a knife and
slices it up on top of the pipe its
sizzles guppy holds her stomach like
she's been punched smells like fish liar
you ain't never had fish
I had fish once too many feathers later
the four girls hunched around their
crate each with a piece of warped tin as
a plate
homemade knives and forks sawed off
plastic soda bottles as cups each filled
with water alley dishes out the cooked
god it looks like grilled whitefish
guppy is in awe wipes at a tear there's
so much alley lifts her cup the rest
raise theirs to the street rats - rats -
street rat alley she did this the girls
dig in its life it's heaven it's
everything this is my favorite food you
always say that you said it last week
when we found that potato potato was my
favorite food last week
now it's GOG do you think we'll eat
tomorrow Ali will try listen the guppy
wanting to eat every day thinks she's a
queen of the bubble do not I just like
eating guppy lets out a huge burp the
girls burst out laughing this is their
joy later the rats clean up their tiny
sewer home getting dark almost no
daylight through the great they light
more candles guppy climbs into her wall
bed one of the lower ones Ali uses
trickling water from an unscrewed pipe
to wash the plates Moonpie leans in
almost whispering copy wants you to talk
her to sleep she wants you Ali Ali
leaves her work and sits by Guppies bed
a hanging sheet and a candle inside
gives him an almost private space guppy
has an ancient beat-up earth globe in
her hands got your earth huh
guppy turns it around traces cities with
her finger what city did the bubble used
to be in nobody really knows but you
have to guess
Ali points to Miami my
[Music]
why just like the sound of it Jimmer
swore it was New York but she didn't
know either what about you
guppy turns the globe to France and
points at Paris Paris if this was Paris
we'd be speaking Parisian silly but
maybe this is what Parisian sounds like
Ali looks confused then impressed are
there really other cities out there like
the bubble ones the train goes to oh
yeah they say if you get on the train
you can go to cities where humans are
still in charge no way humans in charge
just like it used to be before the bots
took over and people you did all the
science and turn themselves into odd
bodies Wow
and you're going there one day it's what
we do street rats all move on to the big
world eventually like jammer and
wrecking girl and gogo red before her
but you're not going soon right
Ali's expression darkens came there
nobody inside the bubble has tickets
cept the big bosses and they ain't
giving him up jammer said she'd send me
a ticket but that was a long time ago
probably forgot I don't blame her she
was way better than me a legend alley
fish is an ancient stuffed rabbit out of
Guppies blankets and puts it in Guppies
arms it's not weird or anything he's
still having a bunny not even a little
hey Ali blows out the candle hey Ali
I think you're a legend
that's sweet
but you can't be a legend until you're
gone she draws the curtain
[Applause]